pas celui là michel rossignol était une
dame de car ils sont car battait pour le
théâtre d'ici et le ter d'aujourd'hui
c'était pour elle la façon d'exprimer
cela de façon magnifique
la grande dame de théâtre a légué la
totalité de ses avoirs soit 1 million
400 mille dollars au théâtre
d'aujourd'hui pour lui permettre
d'écrire le théâtre de demain
une somme qui sera bonifié par le
gouvernement du québec s'est beaucoup
des projets qui sont vraiment en
développement qui sont fortement
orientés aussi sur eux avec eux sur des
valeurs qui étaient chères et michel
était la place des jeunes femmes dans
notre pratique puis la place des
artistes de la diversité au tnm l'avalée
des avalés prend l'affiché vendredi en
salle et en webdiffusion à sa mort
réjean ducharme au légué ses droits
d'auteur au théâtre du nouveau monde
c'est un geste symbolique de la part
d'un auteur qui de manière publique dit
je donne à la culture ce que la culture
m'a donné mais c'est sûr que il ya du
travail à faire en sait on l'a souvent
dit c'est quelque chose qui est très
très présent dans le milieu anglo saxons
et alors que francophones c'est toute
une éducation à faire au rideau vert
aussi les dons sont appréciées que ce
soit avec le programme des jeunes
philanthropes ou au moyen de l'achat de
plaques nominatives sur les sièges vous
pouvez donner 10 $ 20 $ 50 $ c'est
correct on émet des reçus à partir de 20
heures la salle principale du théâtre
d'aujourd'hui sera rebaptisée en
l'honneur de michelle rossignol
à défaut de redonner vie à sa conjointe
ses legs apaise le deuil et contribue à
la rendre éternel sahin pèse beaucoup ça
fait en sorte que
une action en un prolongement pour
longtemps et ça c'est très apaisant un
don pour la création dont nous
bénéficierons tous ici n'est bien l'ex
andré chartier radio canada montréal